Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
It's our 129th episode!
Thank you for joining us today!
Another week of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday aka FUWAMOCO and it's hosted by us,
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please take your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, good morning!
Are you feeling rested?
It's the last day of September.
Almost!
Let's start to a brand new life!
I can't believe it.
Are you ready for it?
Yeah, you're weak!
But I'm ready.
I don't think you're ready for it.
Yeah!
It's almost October!
But you know, the new month means there'll be a bunch more exciting things coming up, especially...
BAU BAU!
We are ready!
But you'll be here with us, right?
So even if things are a little bit scary, it'll be okay because you're here to hold our paws, right?
Right.
Donkey Kong's a horror game too, so... Sometimes, maybe there'll be some Donkey Kong.
This month too.
Nothing better to start off a new month or end off an old month than a bit of disappointment.
Disappointment?
What happened that's disappointing, Moco-chan?
Was it your driving?
No.
I wish you could say it was your driving.
Another Pero Sighting!
Just like every time.
Every time!
Why do we have to start it out every time with a sighting?
Let's see what Pero spotted this time.
Well... De-den!
No sighting!
That's good news!
Nothing.
I couldn't be able to start off a spooky month without something nasty.
This is good!
No nasty start to the day!
A nice start to, you know, the last day of the month.
I have a good feeling that things are gonna be good.
Yeah.
Listen, we did a peril!
We didn't do anything!
No!
No.
Impossible?
Well, look, it happens, so I think it's possible!
Yeah, if Ruffians don't see Pero, then there's no Pero Sightings.
This could be a good sign as to, you know... He's gone.
Gone for... Who knows when.
Yeah, yeah.
Back in the back rooms!
So we have to go find him in the back rooms.
But we don't know where he is.
There's no Sightings, so...
We don't know.
Answer.
BAU BAU!
A little less nastiness in the day today.
That's always good!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Well, there's a bunch of things that went on this weekend.
Yeah!
And one of those big ones was the hololive device 3Gloss!
3Gloss celebrated their 3D debut!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Did you check it out?
Did you see?
They reached the top!
They performed their original songs!
And also, they included some brand new unit songs that will be on their upcoming album ReGLOSS, which is releasing on November 6th.
I always think, you know, I'm so excited for it that I'm like, oh, only a few days from now!
November 6th.
Not October 6th.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we still have to wait a little bit, but that'll make it even more exciting, you know?
And you know, in the 3D Live, they all had a solo song or some sort of moment to showcase themselves individually.
You know, with Aoku performing Shiny Smiley Story.
Very cute.
Mirika in a death match to tell which meat is which and the price.
We had a little bit of Kogeka at the end.
You just got it right!
FUWAMOCO And then Baden with a very cute performance of Montauk around the museum.
It was so cute!
FUWAMOCO And then Banjo with an amazing dance cover!
All those moves!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Us, FUWAMOCO and Biboo, we had our own watchalog here on our YouTube!
So if you're gonna check it out, maybe you wanna watch it together with us too!
And we helped translate some of the MCs a little bit off the top.
And I had some mishaps.
Translation sync.
Yeah, so please check it out and also a big congrats to B-Girls!
Congratulations!
Mama!
Yeah, the translation thing.
It's so embarrassing!
It happens!
BAU BAU!
Well, I'm sure that probably a lot of Ruffians have already heard about this one.
It's next, but there's a huge collab coming up that FUWAMOCO!
We're super excited for you!
There's going to be a special collab with Round1 and hololive!
And it's happening all across Japan and the US!
October 11th!
You know what this means is that you can go to your nearest Round1 and you'll be able to see us standing there!
Do you know what Round1 is?
Oh!
Oh, that's cool.
I don't know what Round1 is, but... I can't see.
It says Bowling at Arcade at the top.
That's a big clue!
Yeah!
Yes!
There's lots of fun stuff there!
There's bowling, arcade, karaoke, just... many fun times all together!
And we're ready to have a bunch of fun with you there!
Yeah!
And there's so many very cute collab items too!
You wanna take a... take a... Yeah!
...take a look at them?
First up, there's our drinks!
We have special flowers for our drinks!
They all kind of match too.
We have flowers!
Powerade Fizz!
Mococo Strawberry Cream Soda!
And they match too, Ruffians!
Yeah, but then we also- IRyS-senpai!
Iris Strawberry Lemonade!
Iris Strawberry.
I see what you did there, huh?
And we have the Ninomaya Mango Cola!
Mango Cola, but there's an orange on the side.
I like it.
That sounds really yummy!
Is that one of Ina-senpai's puns there?
Let's try to pull a fast one high.
And then we have got good sparkling blue soda!
Yeah!
I like how the whipped cream kinda looks like a bit of a fin there, right?
I say they're all gonna be really delicious!
Everyone sort of has a funny spin on their name.
You know, Fuwawa is...
Mococo Cream Soda.
Yeah, it works well, right?
Yeah!
I was just thinking, why is it IRyS-senpai was the only one that got the cherry on top, huh?
Strawberry, but there's a cherry!
Mango, but there's an orange!
It's so amazing I just have like an image of Iris up by drinking the drink and then eating the cherry.
I could see that.
Right?
Yeah.
But you know what?
You get a special random coaster included too!
You can collect all eight!
And you know what that means?
You can bring it home and use it in your room too!
Yeah, just like us.
Yeah, but that's not it.
More not just drinks.
There's merch!
Oh my gosh, it's really tiny.
It's a little bit hard to see.
We'll go over this portion of it.
Yeah.
Well, there's towels.
There's cushions.
Lawn cushions.
Dye towels.
Bath towels.
Bags.
Acrylic diorama stands.
Diorama acrylic stands.
Tote bags.
And they're all very, very cute!
Yeah!
But, Moco-chan... Wow.
There's also... De-den!
Plushies!
Yeah!
And oh, for Ruffians, that
We are in the U.S.
It might be a little bit rough because these are U.S.
limited.
Yeah, they're U.S.
Yeah.
And they're first come first serve.
They're very cute though!
Don't you just want to get your own FUWAMOCO out of the crane?
Can you get them online?
No!
It's crane game prizes.
Crane game prizes.
You have to rescue them!
Time to get good at crane games!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Oh no.
Currently the towels were released on the 11th.
3 new keychains are on the 18th.
And the new creating game items are on the 25th.
Oh she's cute!
And like we said, all items are limited first come first serve.
So Ruffians!
We're wishing you the best day, Mococo!
For all Ruffians that want to try their luck at getting them!
I definitely, definitely want to
Try your best.
Don't fight them other Ruffians, okay?
But Ruffians, make sure you help each other, okay?
I know.
But FUWAMOCO, we're so so excited to be a part of this because for us, arcades have always been a very special place for us as young demon dogs.
We have a lot of memories.
And now, it makes us so happy to think that you're gonna be able to head to Round1 and be able to do those kind of things
Have you ever tried a crane game before, Ruffians?
You know, FUWAMOCO, we're puppies.
Momo-puppies.
But crane games, they're really, really fun.
You buy them!
You may buy them!
Wow, FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians, you know FUWAMOCO, we're not the best at games.
We're very serious though.
But you know what, so creating games might seem kind of impossible to win at first, but really it's perfectly good.
You can do it once you kind of have an idea of just how they work.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO!
We've won a bunch of prizes from crane games.
Even things in the crane game that you weren't supposed to win before, too.
We took a bottom part of the crane game machine.
Yeah.
It was not supposed to go home.
You took it home.
I took it home!
Yeah!
But it's really fun.
We really like playing crane games together with friends.
Yeah, and FUWAMOCO, you know, we can get really noisy.
Yeah.
I guess it's a bit easy though because for some of them you can go sideways and then backwards into the machine right so you get two tries.
So then what we do is one of us obviously is controlling and then the other one looks at the other, the other side.
And then we work as a team together.
So definitely if you have friends together with you please work as a team.
Dear best, I want to see the Ruffians' video of rescuing us from the Great Perroccino!
Please, please show us, okay?
And you know there's also karaoke and bowling like we mentioned!
So uh, maybe you might be able to sing a ballad over there?
Maybe!
Yeah!
But there's lots to see and do, so we really hope that Ruffians that you'll decide to head over to Round1 when it's close to you, far to you.
Maybe you know you can make some travel plans together with some Ruffians near you too.
Please don't push yourself to get them, okay?
And number one, have fun!
It's about having fun!
Do not feel pressured!
Especially, you know, I know it's tricky when we're very, very limited.
What?
You know, there's always a future too, okay?
Don't worry too much!
Have fun!
FUWAMOCO program is mine!
Have fun with everyone!
BAU BAU!
We have some more news for you Ruffians!
This one's brand new, so I'm not sure if you've heard about it yet.
It just happened!
But Suisei-senpai!
She's been up to some really cool things!
Because just a few hours ago, Suisei-senpai, she had a sudden gorilla live in Shibuya!
Just right there on the street!
A street live!
So cool.
Moonlight.
Yeah!
I love this look to the music video and everything!
And you know, it's written by Natori!
I also wrote songs like Overdose and Kobo Senpai's House!
Yeah!
And Moonlight is just such a calming and kind of funky tune!
And it really makes you want to listen to it while driving around the city at night!
It makes sense why Suisei Senpai would perform in Shibuya, though, because it's a very Shibuya song, too.
Yeah, it sounds like a moonlight!
Yeah, moonlight in the moonlight.
But if you haven't been able to see it, please go check out the song on video over on Suisei Senpai's YouTube channel!
Yeah, it's so cool to see Suisei Senpai do cool things like this, right?
Don't watch it live, you know the performance!
Yeah, you know, it'd be cool if we can do even more big things.
Yeah!
We're still just new puppies!
We're growing up!
Yes!
Dream life!
Yeah!
So many amazing things!
Please check it out!
BAU BAU!
Well, I'm still a Ruffian.
Yeah, you know.
It's the end of the month.
Our other senpai's been up to a bunch of different things.
But just the other day, she had her special ocean charity stream!
Did you watch?
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO, we watched too!
You know, she explored a huge aquarium filled with mysterious aquatic... aquatic?
Aquatic?
Aquatic!
No?
Aquatic?
Is that right?
It doesn't sound right anymore.
Huh?
Aqua?
Aquatic?
hololive members too!
Did you see FUWAMOCO?
FUWAMOCO we are there too!
We were cuddle bears!
So cute!
Did you see us?
Yes!
And look, we have the rest of Advent and Shiori.
It looks really terrifying!
Biboo looks really silly.
And Nerissa, well, she's all legs, right?
All legs.
Yeah.
Then we have an Elizabeth Swordfish.
Swordfish!
I'm gonna guess now there's a Catfish.
Catfish!
Botan-senpai.
The Lionfish.
Mumei-senpai.
She's a cute fish.
I don't know which fish.
Is it...
The what's it?
The Owlfish?
Pufferfish?
Pufferfish, yes!
I don't know if that's a pufferfish.
And then we have Gigi the Mudskipper!
Mudskipper!
Yeah!
And Bae-senpai is the... The Bay... Dancing fish?
Betta fish.
Betta... Is that the right one?
I think it's that.
I just can't say the fish names.
Yeah!
Yes!
It was so cool to see everybody!
Everybody there like, oh it's so cute!
Oh!
You got Cecelia the Frog!
It's so cute!
It's so cute
Ohana-senpai, the Alex Coro, the Oopa Loopa.
So cute!
And you know, on top of this amazing world that Ame-senpai has built, she also raised $200,000 towards ocean conservation!
$200,000.
Oh my gosh.
Congratulations!
That's absolutely amazing!
And in case you're interested, you can also go out and check the world in VRChat!
You can go and check out the aquarium.
See all the hololive fish.
Aquatic creatures.
FUWAMOCO don't laugh at me!
I think so.
Yes.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Today is Ame-senpai's last stream at 5 p.m.
PT, 9 a.m.
JST.
Okay!
So let's all be there to say goodbye with a smile, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ame-senpai!
BAU BAU will be there too.
Doggie of the Day!
I'm Doggie of the Day!
It's my time already!
Okay, let's check out who's the Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan.
We have...
Today's Doggie of the Day is Mugi!
What a pretty girl!
So nice smile, those eyebrows too!
Very fluffy.
Those ears... They're not quite as big as my ears, but they're pretty big.
Maybe!
What do you think of the pink collar there, Moco-chan?
Would you like to borrow it?
I like mine okay!
It matches Mugi well too!
Well, Moco-chan, how does Mugi BAU BAU?
Mugi is just a baby.
Mugi, she looks like a very well-behaved girl.
And you know she even BAU BAUs together with us too!
Mugi!
BAU BAU!
I can hear her.
Well, we hope she's a very good sister and that she keeps your parents good company here.
Nothing's better than good company, you know it!
BAU BAU!
And next we have on Today I Went On A Walk.
We have... De-den!
Oh, beautiful day!
First walk in a brand new city!
Congratulations on moving!
BAU BAU!
My shirt was a lot of work.
Moving's never fun enough.
Lots of change.
It can be exciting but a little bit scary too.
I know, we're glad that you were able to get out and take a look at all of your surroundings too.
It's so green.
It really looks like you live in such a beautiful place.
I love that little bridge there too.
Wow, we're very alive.
Yeah, we hope that you enjoy many many wonderful walks around here.
Until maybe bug spray is a good idea.
Maybe, yeah.
Just a thought.
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our Question of the Day!
We have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
We have recorded voice packs for various situations, but you have a voice pack that you both like!
We're looking forward to seeing more voice packs for various situations in the future!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
The extreme love, the four kinds of extreme love.
The yandere voice part was a bit different.
You know?
Maybe just because of some reasons, you know?
I think there was a lot of Ruffians who were hoping that eventually one day we'd do a yandere voice part.
So it was really nice to be able to challenge ourselves to something maybe a little bit more intense and then also
I look forward to all of your reactions.
And if you haven't had a chance to listen to it, you can still go and listen to it.
Yeah, there's a big sample.
Yeah, on the hololive official store, so please go check it out there.
Otherwise, I also like the mischievous preschool pack.
Mainly because that day...
I was really stuffed up.
Like, incredibly stuffed up.
I do not know how many tissues I went through while recording.
So, it really... It really got the... Sort of snotty brat feeling, huh?
Yeah, definitely.
You know, I was a very good school teacher, I think.
Maybe made a couple mistakes here and there, but... My heart was in the right place, so...
We'll continue doing our best in more voice facts too!
It's always a nice challenge, so... Please look forward to that, okay?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, thank you so much for all your submissions!
Remember, if you want to be a part, a bigger part of FUWAMOCO Morning, please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
We're always looking to see who's the doggy of your day.
Maybe it could be the doggy
BAU BAU!
Wow, we have another stream coming up!
Let's take a look at our schedule!
After this, you know, FUWAMOCO, we have a very busy day full of practice and recordings waiting for us.
So the next time we'll be seeing you is for our home 3D reveal tomorrow.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
An advent collab.
This time we're playing not EDF6, we're playing The Forest.
The Forest!
It's the first time that we've ever played a game like this.
I know.
I think we're supposed to live together, work together in the forest.
I said I would because I was seeing comments saying that it's a horror game.
I thought it's like a survival in the forest.
I thought it was a huge dunk in the forest.
Yeah.
Survive the nature.
It's not spooky at all.
Yeah!
Okay, good!
And then on Friday, we have FUWAMOCO Morning, of course.
And then in the evening, we're gonna be watching some very, very funny clips from HoloGTA, talking about it, going over it.
And please, we'll also ask on Twitter for your favorite clips from HoloGTA that are subtitled in English as well.
So please, please send them to us because that'll make things a lot easier.
It would be best if it could be under 10 minutes.
Yes!
Even better if it could be under 3 minutes.
Or under 5 at least.
Yeah.
There's a lot of clips.
So please tag your favorite ones, okay?
And then on Saturday, we're gonna be playing the legendary visual novel Fate Stay Night all together for the very first time.
Yeah!
For the GTA, does it have to be FUWAMOCO?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Anybody.
Yeah, not this FUWAMOCO.
Not this FUWAMOCO.
That would be a little bit embarrassing.
That would be embarrassing!
Yeah, everybody, but please in English sometime.
I say die!
I don't think anyone could do that.
BAU BAU!
I'll see you next week!
For the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO reward!
It's BAU BAU Strawberry Cream Soda!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Kitsuneko!
BAU BAU!
Mystic Mike!
Bossy Up!
BAU BAU!
Viper Blade!
Gokoma!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!